ah Noël le temps des cadeaux le temps du
du partage de la bonté du du don de soi
et si cette année au pied du sapin dans
les petits souliers vous
déposiez du caca oui oui oui je vous
parle bien d'offrir un de vos beaux
étrons bien moulés ah je vous St
intrigué là hein c'est vrai que c'est
pas banal d'offrir du caca comme ça
allez je vous explique ça tout de
suite vous le savez si vous me suivez
depuis le début sur DTC il y a une
petite tradition de fin d'année à Noël
on parle de Don on a déjà parlé de don
de moile osseuse de don de sperme et
donc cette année bah j'ai envie de vous
parler du don de caca parce que oui ça
existe et oui on cherche des volontaires
et ça va vous intéresser vous allez voir
je vais tout vous expliquer mais cette
année petite nouveauté pour rendre tout
ça un peu plus vivant j'ai un envoyé
spécial sur le terrain un donneur de
caca un vrai de vrai en chair et en
crotte d'ailleurs on va tout de suite
tester la connexion pour voir si ça
marche bien Robin est-ce que tu
m'entends salut Julien c'est pas mal
hein on dirait un peu le petit journal
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez quand
il faisait des faux duplexes là en
direct voilà donc je vous présente Robin
il s'est porté volontaire pour un
protocole de don de caca de de recueil
de sel et il va nous raconter au jour le
jour étape par étape comment ça se passe
il va nous emmener avec lui à chaque
fois comme ça pour bien nous montrer
concrètement comment ça se passe donc
restez bien jusqu'au bout vous allez
voir c'est une sacrée aventure mais
avant d'aller rejoindre Robin je vous
explique juste deux trois petits truc et
notamment bah à quoi ça sert et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de tout ce caca
après qu'est- je vais faire de tout ce
caca en gros il y a deux cas de figure
dans lesquels on va chercher des
donneuses et des donneurs de caca soit
pour soigner des gens directement soit
pour faire de la recherche et dans les
deux cas on parle de greffe de caca de
transplantation fécale si vous voulez
être un chouya plus classe et de
transplantation du microbiote fécal si
vous voulez être vraiment très précis
j'en ai déjà parlé mais vite fait comme
ça si vous savez pas vraiment comment ça
marche la greffe de caca une fois qu'on
a récupéré du bon caca de gens qui sont
en bonne santé et surtout qui ont un
microbiote sain le microbiote vous vous
souvenez c'est tous les microbes qu'on a
dans l'intestin et qui font plein de
trucs super importants pour qu'on reste
en bonne santé une fois qu'on a ce bon
caca de bonne qualité et ben on l'envoie
en labo en pharmacie pour qu'il soit
traité pour garder juste le meilleur et
pour qu'il soit conditionné c'est-à-dire
pour qu'on le mette dans les trucs dont
on va se servir pour le donner aux
patients qu'on ont besoin et là il y a
deux possibilité soit on le dilue avec
de l'eau salée et on le met dans des
très grosses seringues qu'on va ensuite
brancher sur des tuyaux qu'on introduira
au patients par voix basse c'est une
expression poli pour dire dans le trou
ou qu'on introduira au patients par voie
haute c'est-à-dire par le nez pour
descendre ensuite dans l'ésophage dans
l'estomac et un tout petit peu après au
niveau de l'intestin grê et après on
envoie la sauce vous étiez pas à table
j'espère deuxième option on le congèle
le caca et on en fait des géules des
géules avec double enveloppe de
protection hein quand même histoire que
ça fonde pas si on le garde un peu trop
longtemps dans la bouche ça a l'air plus
sympa comme ça en géule que en en tuyau
mais dites-vous bien qu'il faut quand
même en avaler une trentaine en une
demi-heure sur de jours mais ça vaut le
coup parce que ça marche très très bien
ça c'était pour poser un petit peu le
contexte mais concrètement un don de
caca comment ça se passe dans le
cadreain le but du protocole auquel il
participe c'est de récupérer le caca de
15 à 20 personnes tous les jours pendant
5 semaines pour faire des
transplantations fécales à des patients
et évidemment avant qu'il soit vraiment
inscrit dans le protocole les médecins
ont vérifié qu'il était en état de donné
pour pouvoir donner son caca dans ce
cadre là bon ça varie un petit peu selon
les cas mais en gros il faut avoir entre
18 et 65 ans ne pas avoir eu de
problèmes intestinaux récemment être en
bonne santé pas de fièvre pas de
d'infection pas d' IST et cetera et puis
il peut y avoir des trucs un petit peu
plus pointu un peu comme avec le don du
sang genre ne pas avoir fait de piercing
ou de tatouage dans les derniers mois le
nombre de partenaires sexuels les
traitements et les antécédents médicaux
et cetera et cetera et puis une fois que
c'est fait une fois que tout ça c'est
bon bah il faut aussi adopter une
hygiène de vie pour garder des bons
cacas de bonne qualité pendant toute la
durée du protocole toi par exemple Robin
tu as des trucs particuliers à faire en
fait le premier rendez-vous que tu vas
avoir avec eux c'est un rendez-vous de
sélection ils vont te donner une liste
de choses à faire et ne pas faire et
notamment adopter le régime de la femme
enceinte donc dès le moment où tu
commences l'étude tu dois éviter tous
les produits crus le lait cru le fromage
au lait cru les sushis la charcuterie
tous ces trucsl il y a quelques petites
cont mais c'est vraiment léger et puis
surtout ça permet d'aider des gens donc
ce serait dommage de pas le faire bah
oui c'est vrai que ce serait dommage et
puis bien sûr avant de commencer les
recueils de sel les dons de caca si vous
voulez et après pendant toute la durée
du protocole régulièrement on s'assure
que vous êtes en bonne santé Robin avant
de commencer tu as des examens à passer
toi ouais il y a des examens alors déjà
dès le début tu vas faire des grosses
prises de sang et des bilan sanguins
complets et après il y a des analyses de
sel et des bilans sanguins tous les 15
jours pour vérifier qu'au fur à mesure
de l'étude tout se passe bien et que de
ton côté tu es toujours en bonne santé
d'ailleurs cet aprem j'ai un gros
rendez-vous avec prise de sang et étude
de sel et je vais t'emmener avec moi ok
donc je change on n'est pas dans le
petit journal en fait manifestement on
est dans une espèce de Spa sorcier on
est un peu les frais déjà mis du
caca bon bref en tout cas vous voyez
pour être donneuse ou pour être donneur
de caca il y a quand même des
contraintes hein il faut aller crotter
tous les jours au labo ou à l'hôpital
faut faire attention à ce qu'on mange il
y a des examens et cetera et cetera faut
être motivé quand même tiens d'ailleurs
Robin pourquoi tu t'es lancé dans dans
un truc pareil toi alors il y a deux
raisons évidemment parce que ça rapporte
de l'argent on va pas se mentir c'est
quand même 70 € le caca ça c'estz
rentable tu peux te faire jusqu'à 1850 €
et en plus être payé pour un truc que je
fais habituellement gratos tous les
jours et qui en plus peut sauver des
gens je trouve ça très très cool sauver
des gens c'est très très cool voilà
j'aurais pas dit mieux moi-même juste
pour le coup de des sous là ça mérite
quand même qu'on s'attarde un petit peu
sur le sujet normalement en France ce
genre de don c'est gratuit on vous paye
pas si vous donnez votre sang votre
moileosseuse vosovosite votre sperme et
cetera c'est un principe de base alors
c'est pas le cas dans tous les pays mais
en France c'est comme ça mais dans le
cas du don de caca il y a un décret qui
autorise l'indemnisation pour compenser
toutes les contraintes que ça implique
et qu'on vient de voir mais attention
déjà c'est pas une rémunération c'est
une indemnisation il y a une nuance et
ensuite cette indemnisation elle est
limitée à 1000 € par mois et à 5000 €
par an bon 5000 € pour un truc que vous
auriez fait de toute façon et que vous
aviez pas particulièrement l'intention
de garder chez vous dans votre salon
c'est quand même pas mal mais là on
parle pas de donner une fois et basta on
parle d'aller crotter tous les jours au
labo ou à l'hôpital pendant 5 semaines
et puis surtout les sous c'est pas
systématique he suivant l'endroit où
vous allez il y en a qui indemnis et
d'autres pas mais bon ça y est c'est
l'heure Robin va aller à son premier
rendez-vous au labo et vu qu'il nous l'a
gentiment proposé bah on va
l'accompagner ça va Robin comment tu le
sens je vais pas vous mentir je suis un
peu stressé il y a deux raisons la
première c'est que je sais que j'ai une
grosse prise de sang et je suis pas trop
fan on va peut-être faire un petit
malaise quand même et la deuxième c'est
que je dois faire un recueil de sel
problème c'est que là j'ai pas tellement
envie et j'ai un peu l'angoisse de la la
feuille blanche quoi allez je suis sûr
que ça va bien se passer on est là on
est tous avec toi et on te dit tous
merde littéralement allez
champion resp bien ouais je vais
respirer bouge pas bouge pas c'est
fait et ben voilà tu vois ça s'est bien
passé voilà donc une fois que ça c'est
fait on peut faire le premier recueil
pour les analyses mais dis donc jamis
comment on chie dans un pot vous avez
une petite poche en dessous qui là est
dépliée vous avez des petites élèves
qu'il va falloir déplier et mettre en
face alors il faut forcer un peu hein
c'est normal en face de la petite flèche
ouais déplier les c'est ce qui va servir
de support pour la cuivette des
toilettes vous enlevez le couvercle pour
pouvoir faire votre recueil vous pouvez
le poser sur la la cuvette directement
très bien une fois que c'est fait vous
fermez bien les quatre
petiteses vous refermez après bien les
sécurit voilà et en fait il va falloir
un petit peu là vous avez une valve pour
enlever l'air poussez un petit peu la
poche ça ferm enever l'air ça marche ça
marche on est d'accord c'est un drone le
machin
non en tout cas c'est pas un pot comme
quand on fait une analyse de caca
classique d'ailleurs une analyse de caca
ça s'appelle une copro culture si vous
voulez vous la péter un peu dans le
milieu on appelle ça une copro comme les
gens chiants qui font des réunions vous
savez pour parler des immeubles et toutà
je suis à peu près sûr que c'est pas un
hasard mais je dis graisse graisse c'est
n'importe quoi cet épisode ça va Robin
tu y arrives les gars c'est le
moment faut que je fasse
gaffe il faut que je pose laoupe volante
comme ça
c ah c'est Chud leur
truc c'est méga chiant
ok bon c'est un peu particulier parce
qu'il y a des gens autour donc là je
suis posé sur posé sur les chiot
concrètement ben je vais vous demander
un petit peu d'intimité on se retrouve
juste après oui on va le laisser
tranquille hein personne n'a envie de
voir ce qui va se passer maintenant de
toute façon vous je sais pas mais pas
moi en tout cas Robin tu nous dis quand
c'est bon
hein ça y est c'est fait ah alors c'est
pas le truc le plus facile à faire de
l'univers faut bien viser en plus mais
j'ai mon petit superir souvenir oui
alors c'est pas un souvenir hein tu
repars pas avec tu le laisses à la dame
en partant tu vas la voir tu lui dis
tenez madame elle va te demander c'est
quoi ça et toi tu lui réponds c'est un
caca voilà bon donc ça c'était le
premier rendez-vous on va retourner voir
Robin pour avoir ses premières
impressions alors bon bah ça y est j'ai
fait mon boulot c'est pas si compliqué
que ça un peu stressant c'est pas le
truc qu'on fait le plus naturellement du
monde aller faire caca dans une
entreprise qu'on connaît pas après il va
falloir faire ça quotidiennement en fait
là ils font les analyses pour vérifier
que tout est ok niveau santé que j'ai
pas de problème qu'il y a pas de microbe
ou autre et ensuite et ben ce sera un
don quotidien donc tous les jours je
vais venir ici salut Martine salut
Philippe puis tu vas faire ta petite
crotte dans ton petit huperroir et puis
voilà ok donc si les analyses de sang et
de celle de Robin sont bonnes et ben ce
sera parti pour des dons de caca
quotidiens pendant 5 semaines on
retournera le voir après pour voir si si
tout se passe bien mais juste avant pour
que vous compreniez bien un truc de base
dans le caca il y a plein de germes
c'est même le principe du microbiote
mais il faut être sûr que Robin a pas
certains microbes qui seraient pas
forcément dangereux pour lui mais qui
pourrait l'être pour la personne à qui
on va faire la transplantation parce que
ça peut être une personne qui est
immunodéprimée par exemple c'est-à-dire
que son système immunitaire est un petit
peu fatigué et qui se défend moins bien
contre certains germes puis bon l'idée
c'est quand même de transplanter un
microbiote sain voilà donc c'est pour ça
qu'on fait des analyses alors Robin du
coup pour toi c'est bon c'est ok c'est
parti ça y est c'est parti c'est le
jourg euh première livraison effectué
c'est parti pour un mois maintenant
alors je suis pas ultra serein parce que
tu es dans des ils ont fait un espèce de
préfabriqué de chiotte mais ça va ça va
le faire mais oui ça va le faire allez
Marcel fais chauffer la gomme alors vous
vous demandez peut-être qu'on peut bien
soigner avec du caca bah pour l'instant
on peut soigner des infections
intestinales à une bactérie
particulièrement pénible le Clostridium
difficile mais il y a plein d'études en
cours sur d'autres indications parce
qu'on pense que ça pourrait être aussi
efficace sur les maladies inflammatoires
de l'intestin mais aussi sur plein de
trucs qui a priori n'ont rien à voir
parce qu'on sait que le microbiote il
est impliqué dans plein de choses comme
des troubles du développement des
maladies neurodégénératives des maladies
PSI des maladies métaboliques et cetera
et cetera d'où les recueils de caca pas
seulement pour les soins mais aussi pour
la recherche on retourne le voir ça va
Robin ça se passe toujours bien il a un
problème que j'avais pas anticipé c'est
que hier soir je crevais d'envie d'aller
au chot et je me suis retenu parce que
j'avais peur de pas pouvoir y aller
aujourd'hui donc je dois faire caca sur
commander c'est pas facile ah oui pas
facile ça en plus faut faire attention
faut pas trop se retenir normalement
parce que vu que l'eau du caca elle est
réabsorbé au niveau du colon c'estàd là
tout à la fin juste avant de sortir si
vous le gardez trop longtemps à cet
endroitlà bah il y a trop d'eau qui part
et le caca il devient tout sec et il
devient tout dur donc au mieux quand ça
sort bah ça pique et au pire bah ça sort
pas du tout donc évitez de vous retenir
sauf si vous avez pas le choix
évidemment mais et pendant ce tempsl
Robin continue son petit bonhomme de
chemin comme le comme le petit Pousset
bon sauf que lui c'est pas des cailloux
qui sème à priori on va retourner voir
si tout va bien ça y est les gars c'est
arrivé panne sèche je savais que ça
arrivera un jour mais je pensais pas que
ce sera aujourd'hui je
repars les poches vides et le ventre
plein ah merde enfin non justement
j'espère que c'est pas moi qui t'ai
porté la poisse avec mes histoires de
caca tout sec bon ceci dit j'imagine que
ça doit arriver souvent on est quand
même pas des machines et je discutais
avec l'opératrice qui me disait qu'il y
en a qui viennent deux à trois fois par
jour sachant que c'est payé à la crotte
ça devient rentable mais par contre faut
avoir un transit de compétition faut
bouffer des pruneaux à tous les repas et
par contre 70 € la crotte donc 210 € sur
une journée de caca c'est plutôt
rentable oui mais alors attention il y a
un plafond de toute façon comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est normal de se dire
qu'on va se faire des sous juste en
crottant dans un drone comme ça c'est
tentant mais en 2018 il y a une étude
qui a été stoppée à cause de ça
justement cette étude elle était
coordonné par le professeur Harry soolle
de l'hôpital Saint-Antoine à Paris et il
se trouve que je l'ai contacté pour
préparer cette vidéo et il m'a confirmé
qu'à l'époque il proposait 50 € pardon
et que l'étude a dû être arrêté parce
qu'ils avaient été submergés par les
demandes et les volontaires c'est pas la
faute des volontaires attention c'était
un problème de communication et
d'organisation aujourd'hui des
protocoles il y en a beaucoup plus et
des volontaire je vous ai dit on en
cherche donc si ça vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien dans la description
de la vidéo c'est un test que vous allez
pouvoir faire en ligne pour voir si vous
pouvez donner enfin si vous êtes
éligible juste après faudra aller voir
un médecin faudra faire un entretien des
analyses de sang des analyses de sel
comme Robin et cetera et cetera comme je
vous ai dit il faut s'assurer que tout
est ok avant de commencer et c'est
vraiment loin d'être toujours le cas
parce que le médecin m'a dit que au
final il y a que 5 % des volontaires qui
sont effectivement retenus allez c'est
le moment de retourner prendre des
nouvelles le Robin comment ça se passe
champion tu as pris le rythme bon ben la
mauvaise nouvelle vient de tomber euh
appelé directement par le médecin du
centre qui fait les collectes pour
m'informer qu'il y a une bactérie dans
mes selles bactérie qui est inoffensive
pour moi qui est apparemment une forme
deschérich à colis et le médecin
m'explique que quand on est en bonne
santé ce qui est mon cas on vit très
très bien avec mais ce qui peut être
extrêmement dangereux pour les personnes
qui doivent recevoir les
transplantations fécales donc il préfère
sécuriser et me retirer de
l'étude il y a 16 personnes à la base et
j'ai l'impression que ça tombe pas mal
donc ils essayent de vraiment faire
attention pour ne rien risquer donc
voilà le don de caca c'est déjà terminé
pour moi adieu la nouvelle cuisine et
bonjour le restaurant pour deux en
amoureux c'est déjà bien aïe aïe aïe la
poisse voilà c'est c'est exactement ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure faut
être sûr que le microbiote est sain pour
pas mettre la receveuse ou le receveur
en danger d'où l'intérêt de faire des
analyses régulièrement désolé champion
hein une prochaine fois j'espère bon ben
voilà l'aventure s'arrête là pour Robin
encore un grand merci à lui de nous
avoir permis de l'accompagner de faire
un petit bout de chemin avec lui un
grand merci aussi au professeur Harry
sookol pour le temps qui m'a consacré et
pour toutes ses infos sur le don de caca
si le microbiote ça vous intéresse et
que vous aimez la BD bah il en a écrit
une sur le sujet je vous mets le lien
dans la description de la vidéo vous
pouvez aussi retourner voir la vidéo que
j'avais faite pour le vortex d'art dans
laquelle je parlais de toutes les
utilisations futures et possibles du
caca et notamment bah la transplantation
fécale et celle sur le microbiote que
j'ai fait avec l'Institut Pasteur je
vous mets tout ça vous savez si ça vous
intéresse de devenir donneuse ou donneur
de caca bon voilà je pareil je vous ai
mis toutes les infos juste une petite
info une fois que vous êtes retenu dans
un protocole bah vous pouvez donner
autant de fois que vous voulez c'est pas
comme le don du sang là c'est de toute
façon un truc que vous allez faire tous
les jours donc ça va pas vous manquer ça
va pas mettre votre santé en danger par
contre je vous ai dit vous allez pas
forcément être indemnisé renseignez-vous
avant et même si c'est le cas c'est
plafonné hein donc vous n'allez pas
faire fortune avec ça alors encore une
fois par les temps qui court gagner de
l'argent avec son caca on va pas cracher
dessus je suis d'accord mais tant qu'on
y est si je peux me permettre vu que
c'est Noël en plus pensez peut-être à
faire un don aussi même quand c'est pas
payé un don du sang par exemple ça on en
manque toujours vous inscrire sur le
registre des donneurs de moileosseuse là
vous pouvez littéralement sauver une vie
avec une simple prise de sang donnez vos
gamettes vos ocites ou votre sperme
selon les cas là vous sauverez pas des
vies mais vous aiderez des gens à en
créer une et il y a beaucoup plus de
personnes qui sont en attente de dons
qu'il y a de donneus et de donneurs donc
faites comme vous voulez mais pensez-y
voilà je vous ai mis toutes les infos
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fore